The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So today we finish our
game characterization.
We have this giant table.
We've done two players, zero
players, one player, of course.
That's the oldest.
Today we're going to do
team imperfect information
games, which when you
have a polynomial bound
on the number of moves,
you get NEXPTIME--
nondeterministic
exponential time.
This is the exponential
version of NP.
And for games with unbounded
number of moves-- normally,
I would say exponentially
many moves, but, in fact,
this will be really
unbounded, could
be close to infinitely many
moves-- we get Undecidability,
so no algorithm,
whatsoever, to solve it.
We don't know any natural
games in these classes.
But I have a couple of
question marks here.
Bridge is an example of a game
with imperfect information
and teams in one hand.
And it has bounded play.
Once you play your cards--
all of the cards are down--
you're done.
So potentially, it
falls in this class.
Although, I don't know if
Bridge is sophisticated enough
or-- it depends on your
notion of the bidding rules
and what can be
communicated there.
On the other hand, for
the unbounded game,
one candidate problem is
called Rengo Kriegspiel.
Kriegspiel is blind chess.
Rengo Kriegspiel is
blind Go with teams.
So there are two black
players, two white players.
And you make moves
without knowing
what the other moves of
any of the other players
are, usually by writing
on a piece of paper
and giving it to some
referee who tells you
whether that was valid.
This is a game
people actually play.
And I'm told-- I know
Bob Hearn has played it.
He likes playing Go.
But it's open, whether that
problem is Undecidable.
Potentially, yes.
That seems more likely.
And then finally, one other
cell that we didn't do,
which I'll get to
after those two,
is this box, which sounds
pretty boring because it's just
polynomial time things--
polynomial bounded zero player
games.
It's just like Game of Life
running for a polynomial amount
of time.
You can generate-- I mean,
you can solve those problems
in polynomial time.
But there's a stronger sense
in which all polynomial time
problems can be represented,
say, by Game of Life.
And this, actually, is
relevant to parallel computing.
And it essentially says,
there's no good way
to parallelize Game of
Life, among other problems.
So I mentioned that way
back in lecture one.
And a lot of people
said, oh, what's
this P-completeness business?
And so today we will
cover that, as well.
But let's start with
NEXPTIME and Undecidability.
Let's start with a bounded case.
So in the bounded case,
there's this cool paper
by Peterson and
Reif, introducing
a problem variation of QSAT.
Remember, QSAT,
also known as QBF.
So this is DQBF.
And it's a funny problem.
First, I'll phrase it
as a formula problem.
And then I'll talk
about it as a game.
So normally, in QSAT QBF, we
have N alternating quantifiers.
And that's PSACE complete.
And every quantifier can depend
on all of the previous values.
But now we're going
to have two sort
of in parallel
existential quantifiers.
So we have two universal--
I should mention the capital
letters.
That's a bunch of variables.
So there's like N bits
here, N bits here that
has to work for all
choices of those.
Why do I separate them out?
Because over here, I'm
going to separate them out.
And Y1-- the choice of Y1 is
only allowed to depend on X1.
And the choice of Y2 is only
allowed to depend on X2.
And then we're going
to have some CNF
formula on the X1, X2, Y1, Y2.
So we can think of that
as this is one player.
It could be two players.
But it doesn't really matter.
So make it one-- simpler.
It's going to be a
three player game.
Black makes these choices.
And then white player
1 chooses the Y1s.
And the private information
aspect of this game
is that the white player one
can only see the X1 variables--
choices made by black.
Maybe it's more
intuitive to think
of this as a four player game.
There are two black players.
And the white 1 player
can see the values chosen
by the black 1 player
but not the values
chosen by the black 2 player.
And then, over here, we have
white player two, who can only
see the variables chosen-- X2.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Does the black
team have full information?
PROFESSOR: Black team
has full information.
I mean, the black
team goes first.
So it doesn't,
obviously, see Y1 and Y2.
But they can see each other.
Yeah.
So X2 can see X1.
So if I don't write a
parenthetical dependency,
then it can depend
on everything.
Yeah.
Really, this is one player.
So they get to choose
everything in the X [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
So then the question
is given this--
I mean, this quantified
formula's equivalent to saying,
can white force a
win, where white wins
if that formula is satisfied?
And white collectively
needs to make these choices.
But it's acting as a team
with impartial information.
So it's not acting
as a single player
anymore, unlike when we
had full information.
Then three players
was the same as two.
OK?
So let's first observe
that this is in NEXPTIME.
And then, furthermore, the
claim, which I won't prove,
is that this is
NEXPTIME complete.
So the idea is there are only
exponentially many choices
for these variables.
So then I can guess--
both player 1 and player 2
can guess what--
white 1 and white 2
can guess what the possibilities
are for all possible choices
of X1 and X2.
So they're making
exponentially many guesses.
For every state of X1, X2, guess
what the right strategy is.
And then just combine--
then check whether everyone
plays properly.
So then white can decide
whether they can win.
That's cool.
This can be reduced to a bounded
team, private information
version of constraint
logic-- TPCL.
Let me define that.
We're going to do this
with three players
And a plane or a graph.
I think just and/or
graph is enough.
But it's a team.
There are going to be,
again, two white players,
one black player.
And it's private
information, meaning
that each edge is marked
as visible to white
or visible to black.
Now, the figures-- it's
a little hard to draw.
So the figures--
the color is just
indicating whether that player
is allowed to flip that edge.
Each player can only flip--
each white player can only
flip white edges.
Black player can only flip
black edges, just like before.
Well, now it's
white team can only
flip-- either of
the white players
can only flip a white edge.
So some edges are
flippable by two players.
But then, in addition, some
edges-- some white edges
are going to be marked
as invisible to black.
And some black edges
are going to be
marked as invisible to white.
And furthermore, you can say
invisible to this white player
or this white player.
OK?
So it's a little
bit more general.
And the rules of the
game are pretty simple.
You can make moves
just like before.
But you must be able to know
that that move is legal.
So unlike Rengo
Kriegspiel, you're
not allowed to make
impossible moves.
You must know, based on the
information that you can see,
that the movie is valid.
There are probably other
variations that work.
But this is a clean
one to work with.
So if you can see
all of the edges,
or you see that there's enough
incoming white to an edge,
then you can reverse one of
the ones you have control over.
So this problem-- I mean,
so a funny thing about DQBF
is that there's sort of
only one round to the game--
I mean, black plays,
white plays, white plays,
and then you see who won--
whereas most games we think
of as having many rounds.
And in particular, bounded
TPCL has many rounds.
They play in round robin.
You've got black, white 1, white
2, black, white 1, white two.
And you play in that
sequence, over and over.
Each turn, someone's just
reversing a single edge,
whereas over here, you're
choosing a ton of variables.
Turns out this problem
is also in NEXPTIME,
essentially because if there is
a winning strategy for white,
over here, that winning
strategy is deterministic.
And it's just a function
of the visible state.
And there are at most
N different edges
that you can see.
So the number of possible
states is exponential.
So at the beginning, you
just guess your strategy.
That's exponentially
many bits to guess.
So in NEXPTIME, you can do that.
And then you just play
deterministically,
with that strategy.
So even though the game may
run for a very long time,
and you do many,
many rounds, still,
the information you need to
guess was only exponential.
So you can do this in NEXPTIME.
So it's a funny thing here.
In this particular
world, unlike all
of the other cells
of that matrix,
one round versus many
rounds is the same.
You get NEXPTIME
completeness in both cases.
OK.
So let me tell you how we reduce
from DQBF to bounded TPCL.
So many acronyms.
So the idea's pretty simple.
Again, we want
black to play first.
So there's a bunch of
black variables, here,
which are represented by this.
These two figures
are almost the same.
Just these edges are blacked
down here and white down here.
That's going to correspond
to the variable setting.
In this context, we only want
variables to be set once.
You don't get to reset them
because it's a bounded game.
As in all of the bounded
constraint logic games,
you can only flip
each edge once.
Question?
AUDIENCE: It's kind of a
question about your earlier
point, but could you
clarify the difference
between why having one
round of one of the games
is equivalent to having
all-around [INAUDIBLE] game?
PROFESSOR: I don't have
an intuitive reason
why-- only that this game
is in NEXPTIME and this game
is NEXPTIME complete.
I mean, they both are
NEXPTIME complete.
So in that sense,
they're equivalent.
Yeah.
So we're going to
simulate this one round
game with multiple
rounds, over here.
But yeah.
It's a little bit odd that
alternation doesn't help.
It doesn't give you more power.
All of the other game
settings that it does.
So it's just a weird
thing about team.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are you [INAUDIBLE]
kind of rely on the fact
that white doesn't learn
anything from black's moves
when black moves on
an invisible edge?
Sorry.
It seems like in some
board configurations,
if black moves on
an invisible edge,
you can actually
learn something based
on what moves were allowed,
and not allowed, for black.
PROFESSOR: Maybe I
should say that passing
is allowed in this game.
Otherwise, the fact that you
moved does tell you something.
But if you're always
allowed to pass,
you really have no idea
whether something happened,
except by what was visible.
Yeah.
So that's-- make explicit,
passing is allowed.
Yeah, these are a bit subtle.
OK.
So the intent is, first, we
let black choose variables,
either by flipping true edge,
flipping the false edge.
We want to set it up
so you can't do-- well,
you can't do both because
of this vertex constraint.
So that's cool.
As soon as that
happens, probably, white
will flip this edge and
black will flip this edge.
That's a split, activating--
well, not yet activating
the formula part, but enabling
black to activate the chosen
edge, saying that this
variable has been chosen.
And so black will
sort of output that.
Then in here, so there's
n such variables.
And B1 and B2 are both in here.
And we take the and of
all of those chosen edges.
And that's this chosen wire.
So this-- black is
motivated to do this.
Black wants to set
their variable some way.
And they could, I
guess, set them back
and change the variables.
But there won't be any
motivation to do that.
The goal for black is
to flip this edge, which
is connected by a long path from
the AND of all of the chosen
wires.
So basically, B has to
choose all of the variables,
get this AND to be true,
and then just sit there,
flipping these edges,
until this edge is flipped.
So that's a threat line, once
B has set their variables.
So B is going to
race to do that.
White is going to have
just enough time to satisfy
the formula and flip this
edge if the formula was true,
obviously.
So what happens next--
white will basically
sit there and
twiddle their thumbs,
flipping some useless
edge, until all
of the black variables are set.
They could actually
do something else.
But there's going to
be enough time to wait.
So it's better to wait.
Then the white variables can
depend on the black variables
that it can see.
Obviously, pretty much
all of the edges in here
are visible to only one
of the white players.
If this is a B1
variable, then this
is only visible the white 1.
White 1 can see
that it was chosen
but can't see which
of these edges
got flipped and can't
see which of these edges
got flipped or these ones.
OK?
So that's representing
the visibility.
And so then white will
set their variables,
the same kind of construction.
And once chosen is
activated for both of them,
we take the AND here, and
we trigger the unlock paths.
It's going to unlock the white
1, unlock the white 2, unlock
all of the black variables.
And the unlock part is what
lets you trigger the formula
activation.
So if true was selected
here, and this was flipped,
once the unlock is
flipped, then this guy
can activate and start inputting
all of the true variables
into the formula.
And then white will sit there
and evaluate the formula.
It has just enough time, if it's
satisfied, to flip and be done.
So that's how we
represent dependency QBF.
I mean, it's pretty natural.
It's just some fun stuff
to get these to happen
in essentially two rounds.
The visibility constraints of
the partial-- the privateness
of visible information
makes this part really easy
to implement.
So no big surprises.
Questions?
OK.
Let's go to the
unbounded case, which
is the much more exciting one.
So I mean, Undecidability
is weird and unusual.
It's weird in this
context because this game
has finite resources.
All of our games--
in particular,
in constraint logic-- you
have some graph of size n.
And Undecidability is
about, essentially,
simulating a Turing machine
for arbitrary amounts of time
and arbitrary amounts of space.
It's bigger than 2 to the n.
It's bigger than
2 to 2 to the n.
It's bigger than 2 tower.
And it's bigger than
any-- I guess, it's
any computable function of
n is how far you have to go.
So a little bit less
than busy beaver.
That's a lot of space.
So in game graph,
we can't represent
the state of the machine that
we're trying to simulate.
So I should say-- we haven't
done Undecidability at all,
but the canonical
problem to start from
is a halting problem.
You're given a Turing machine.
And here, I'd like
to say algorithm,
but we need some model
of the machine growing
to arbitrarily large sizes.
And this Turing machine
is really ideal for this.
Given the Turing machine,
does it ever halt?
So remember, a Turing
machine, you have some tape.
Let's say, initially, all of
the tape squares are empty.
You have some pointer
into the tape, starts
at some canonical position.
And you can read and
write squares in the tape.
And you can move left and right.
And that's it.
The feeling, as this
corresponds-- this
includes all
possible computation.
And so deciding whether
this machine will ever
finish-- so there's an
instruction that just says,
halt-- or whether to just
keep going on forever seems--
is provably impossible.
There is no algorithm
to decide that,
essentially because it's an
algorithm to study algorithms.
But I won't prove that here.
I'm going to reduce
from this problem.
And so I need to be able to
simulate a Turing machine
of arbitrary size and time.
Cool.
So while most of the time
I don't show you the source
problem, I think, here, it's
instructive to see-- well,
I guess I'm not proving
this as undecidable.
But it's instructive to see
how we turn this into a game,
with bounded resources.
So before I get to the
constrain logic version,
I'm going to talk about
something called a team
computation game-- this is
from our book, Games, Puzzles,
Computation-- that will allow
us to simulate the halting
problem, but using
finite resources.
This is where the action is.
Going from here to
a constrain logic
is not that hard and
not super interesting.
But this part is
quite interesting.
OK.
So in team computation
game, there's
going to be three players--
one black player, two
white players.
And the instance to the game--
sort of the board set up,
whatever-- is
going to be-- here,
I could use any algorithm
or Turing machine.
It's going to be machine.
And it has some
space bound which
are called k. k is going to
be, essentially, a constant.
But it's part of the input.
And the idea-- if
this is an algorithm,
it starts with blank memory.
If it's a Turing machine,
it starts with a blank tape.
And then we're going to define
black moves and white moves.
So remember, there's
one black player.
And what the black player does,
or what the black player's
forced to do, is run the
algorithm or the machine
for k time steps.
So k obviously is an input.
So black is forced to do that.
Now, that algorithm
may return an answer.
And the answer is always
black wins or white wins.
Or it may not do
anything, in which case
it wants to keep running.
In the next black
move, it's going
to run for another k steps.
And in the next black moves,
it runs for another k steps,
and so on.
Think of k as a constant.
So if there's output from
this algorithm or machine,
that will determine the winner.
OK?
And otherwise, black actually
gets to make a choice.
This was completely forced,
what black had to do here.
You could think of it
as part of black's move.
But it's really-- the game
mechanics make this happen.
And in this case, black can
set two variables-- X1 and X2--
to be anything in
the set A, B. OK?
Black gets to choose two
bits if the machine doesn't
say that the game is over.
OK?
We'll see what those
bits do, in a moment.
So that was black's move.
Now, what about white?
Again, there are two
players-- white 1 and white 2.
And white i is basically blind.
White i can only see Xi.
These Xis are messages
to the white players.
And that's all
that white can see.
White can't see anything
else about the machine.
Good that it knows what
the machine is, knows what
it's doing, probably knows k.
But that's because that's
all part of the instance.
But you don't know anything else
about the state of the machine.
And white can also
do one other thing.
There's one memory cell
in the machine, called M1.
And there's another
one called M2.
And player white i can set Mi.
And so that will
communicate, back
into the machine,
what white i did.
And that is exactly
the move of white i.
White i move is just set Mi.
And I'm not specifying
how big that is.
It's not just a single bit.
It could be some stuff.
In particular, it's going to be
one cell in the Turing machine
we want to simulate,
essentially.
But OK.
So now the question is, does
white have a forced win?
So this is the problem I
want to prove undecidable
by a reduction from
halting problem.
OK.
So is the problem clear?
We have a finite setup, which
is this space k situation,
that the entire state of
the game is, in some sense,
encoded by that-- the state of
that algorithm, it would seem.
And black is just
telling-- in each turn,
white 1 says A or B, white 2, it
says A or B. White 1 and 2 then
respond with some symbol.
And then the game continues.
So a pretty simple setup.
But amazingly, this can
simulate any Turing machine.
So let's do it.
So this algorithm is
going to be a function.
Given the Turing
machine, we're going
to construct the
algorithm, naturally.
So we basically need a
constant space algorithm
to check that the
white players produce--
so the white players are
outputting a strain of symbols.
White 1 is outputting M1 and
then outputting something
else to M1, and so on.
That strain of symbols,
for both white players,
should essentially form a
valid computation history,
an execution trace
of the Turing machine
we want to simulate--
the given Turing machine.
It's a little bit more
complicated than that.
But that's the idea.
And we'd like it to
end in a halt state.
So there are lots
of canonical ways
to write down the state
of the Turing machine.
Basically, you
write down the tape
and what instruction it's on.
And that should be about it.
And we're going to put
a special symbol-- hash
mark-- in between
each of these states.
So this is the state of
the machine at time 0.
It's going to be a blank tape.
And you only have to write
as many symbols as you need.
So in the beginning,
don't write any symbols.
As you start writing stuff to
tape, this will get longer.
And yeah.
And then the goal is to
get it to a halt state.
Each of these states should be
the uniquely determined state
from the previous one, which
is, if I do one instruction,
what happens?
OK?
Now, this is problematic.
So our goal-- we're trying
to design this algorithm
to confirm that these states
are being generated correctly.
That's really hard to do because
we can't compute the next state
from the previous one
because we can't even
store the previous
state in space k.
We have constant space.
Very soon, the state
is going to get huge.
So you think of this as kind
of a streaming [INAUDIBLE]
We're just seeing
these characters go by.
And we can't remember the
entire previous states.
So the fact-- to check
that the next state is
almost the same as the
previous one is very hard.
And that's where we're going
to use this A, B thing.
This is not literally true.
The sequence of
characters-- M1, say--
will not produce a valid state.
Essentially, what we
want player white 1
to do is to maintain two
pointers into this state--
A and B. And when we-- I'm
identifying with black here.
When we specify X1
equals A, we would
like to know what character's
being pointed to by pointer A.
And then we'd like to advance
A to the next character.
OK?
When we request B,
with X1 equals B,
we want to know what
character is at position B,
and then advance to
the next character.
So there's one strain that
we're trying to look at.
And each white player has to
maintain an A pointer and a B
pointer.
And as black, we can
make independent requests
to each of the two.
It's like you have two disks
with two heads on the disk.
And they both have
the exact same data.
Or they're supposed to.
And I can say, give
me the next character
at this pointer from this disk.
And I can give you-- ask for
what is-- simultaneously,
I get one character
from one of the two
pointers on the other disk.
And then it advances by one.
OK?
Seems almost the same.
But that's what will
make this undecidable.
OK.
So here's the trick, how we're
going to build this algorithm.
I mean, the real trick is
that we have nondeterminism.
We're asking whether white wins.
That means-- or whether
white has a winning strategy.
For white to have
a winning strategy,
that must mean it can win or the
white team can win, no matter
how black plays.
And black is just non--
so basically, black
is nondeterministically
choosing between the A
and the B pointer requests.
And so what this is
saying is, no matter
what sequence of As and Bs
you get, white must win.
And winning is going
to happen because we
will build this algorithm to
only output yes when it gets
to a halt state, basically.
The algorithm must not
complain, no matter how
we choose the A and B sequence.
So let me get to what
we're going to do.
So the algorithm maintains--
let's call this white 1.
I would like to
know when-- let me
be specific-- when white 1's A
state equals white 2's B state.
But in fact, we'll do
this for all pairs.
It'll be four different things.
A, B here.
But let's say I want to
know when white 1's A
state is in exactly the same
place as white 2's B state.
So we have-- in
some sense, there
are two of the strains, one
for white 1, one for white 2.
And I want to know when I have
just to read through a state
by white 1 and I've also read
through the exact same state
from white 2.
So that will happen when--
first of all, both white players
should have just
returned a hash mark.
And then-- hash
tag, if you prefer.
And then also, while we were
running through this tape,
I see whether they happen to
always return the same result.
So this will basically
happen when-- so whenever
both A and-- so if we just ask
for A, A, and white 1 returns
a hash mark and white
2 returns a hash mark,
then we're going to
start paying attention
to every single
character we see.
If-- assuming we keep
playing A, A, is black.
And this has to work for all
possible assigned choices of A,
B. So in particular,
it will be an execution
where we play A, A
throughout this entire state.
And as we're doing that, we just
check, character by character,
are they returning
exactly the same result,
and have they, so
far-- have they always,
since the last hash mark?
OK?
And if they did, that's a
constant space algorithm.
I just compare
character by character.
Remember the AND of all
of those comparisons.
If they were all the same,
and I reach a hash mark,
that means I know that both
the W1 strain and the W2
strain just output
the same state.
So that means the A
and the A pointers
are in the same
place at this moment.
Cool.
That's not quite
where I want them.
But at least I can detect that.
OK?
I can detect identical states.
Remember, I can't even
store-- I can't even
count A and B
because these could
get to really huge numbers.
That only buys me an exponential
when I write things in binary.
So I can't afford to write
down the A and the B pointers.
It's what I'd like to do.
But I can check, oh, did they
just output the same state?
So far so good?
Now, what I'd really like them
to be is one step out of sync
because what I do have a
streaming algorithm for is
if I have the previous
data of the Turing machine
and the proposed next date
of this Turing machine,
and I compare them letter
by letter, I can just check,
are all of the tape squares
identical except for the one
that the pointer's on?
And that got changed
by a simple rule.
And then all the others
should be identical.
So it's very easy,
in a streaming sense.
If I'm giving the previous
state and the next state,
I'd be happy.
So my goal is to get W1 state
to be one step out of sync,
one step behind W2 state.
OK.
So how can I make that happen?
Again, so I mean, black
isn't really making-- well,
black is making all possible
choices among A and B,
at all times.
So in particular, we can
consider the situation
in which black plays, let's
say A for the W1 player,
and plays B on the other player.
W2's A state does not change
because we're advancing B.
And then W1's
state is advancing.
And if I keep doing that,
and then, at some point,
I get a hash mark,
which I can obviously
detect in constant space,
then I advance my finite state
machine, and say,
OK, cool, that means
W1 is one step ahead--
one state ahead of W2.
And now I'm going to compare.
So when that happens, so
then out of sync by 1.
And now what I'd like to
happen next is X1 and X2 moves.
Then now I'm going to run
my streaming algorithm
to check that this was
a valid transition.
So from whatever
W2 is outputting
to whatever W1 is outputting
because W1 is ahead,
that should be a valid state.
So basically, I had--
I ran for some time.
Who knows what happened.
Then I got this thing which
is identical to this thing.
I detect that.
And I see a hash mark.
So I say, OK, they must
be in the same state.
Now I'm going to
skip over whatever
state was written here.
And then I'm going to check
that every thing I get here
is a valid transition
for whenever I get here.
So this should go to that.
This should go to that.
And I don't need any
memory to do this.
I'm just looking at
this square, knowing
the state of this machine,
looking at this square,
making sure that was
a valid transition.
Usually, it's just that
this is equal to that,
except at the one place
where the tape head is,
which is written in
that little symbol.
And in that spot, I do
whatever the Turing machine
does to that symbol.
If the writes to
it, it might change.
Maybe it moves the
pointer left or right.
But in constant
space, I just need
to know what's happening here.
And maybe it's
neighboring squares.
I can figure out what
should be written here.
And if white 1 ever
does the wrong thing,
if it's not a valid
transition, then I
will say black wins
as this algorithm.
So for white to win, it
can't make any mistakes.
White has to conform to this
idea that basically, first,
it-- well, it basically--
as it's playing,
it must be computing whatever
the Turing machine that's
part of the game, essentially.
It's embedded in this
algorithm, the Turing machine.
And so we have to-- it has to be
simulating the Turing machine,
maintaining these pointers,
A and B, and running through.
It has to do that
because it has to win,
no matter what black does.
And it could be that black
does this really weird sequence
of As and Bs in order to
verify the one place where
you lied about one of these
being an invalid transition.
It will eventually check for
some choices of the A and B
moves.
It will check that it
was a valid transition,
from here to here.
And therefore, all
transitions must be valid.
So it's a pretty crazy
use of essentially
the universal quantifier
that's given to black.
White has to win, no matter
what black's moves are.
So you might ask, where is
the Turing machine state.
And it's essentially
in the heads
of the white players, which
are not represented directly
by the game.
The game is just, you know, what
is the state of this algorithm?
And it's, in some sense,
informed by the history
of the plays, the sequence
of moves that have been made.
That's, in some sense,
where you can also see
this long sequence of moves.
I mean, each of these
got output at some point.
But initially, you could sort of
think of, all of the execution
was in the players' heads.
Then they're just maintaining
these A and B pointers
and playing.
And there must be such an
execution in order for white
to win.
So white will win, if, and only
if, there's a-- the machine
halts, basically, because this
algorithm only output yes--
output that white wins
when the machine halts.
And it will report that black
wins, if you ever cheat.
So you have to not cheat.
And you have to get
to a halting state.
It's pretty crazy.
And this probably won't make
sense the first or second time.
But it's clear to me,
again, every time I learn.
It's like, oh, yeah,
that's really cool.
Hopefully, it will
become clear to you.
But if there are any questions--
AUDIENCE: Why is it
important that the algorithm
is only one space, in
the first place, though?
PROFESSOR: I mean,
it's not technically--
the overall algorithm is not
technically constant space
because it needs to include the
entire Turing machine as part
of it, to know how to run.
But I mentioned that
the checking algorithm
is constant space.
And the point is, really, that
the size of this space key
algorithm has to be only a
function of the given Turing
machine.
It can't depend on the
execution time or the execution
space of the Turing machine.
But that's all I
want to emphasize.
So effectively, I mean, if you
think of the Turing machine
as being pretty small,
but it's running
for some huge amount of
time, like busy beaver time,
relative to that, we're
thinking, basically,
constant space.
And in fact, we can get
away with constant space.
That's for the checking part.
That's my point.
If you view the Turing machine
execution as an oracle.
So when I check that this
goes to this-- in fact,
I have to run the Turing
machine on this tape head input,
to see what it would output.
But the Turing machine
is inside the algorithm.
So I can do that and
[INAUDIBLE] some time
with the lookup table.
So the point is, really, you
need, effectively, a streaming
algorithm to do this
because these states get
to be really, really
huge, because we
want this reduction
to be polynomial time.
And it is.
Basically, copy the
Turing machine over,
write some constant amount
of code to do this checking,
and that's all you need.
I guess we don't need it
to be polynomial time.
But it is.
So it's kind of nice.
But we need that
it's finite time.
And there's no finite way
to give an upper bound
on the running time
of the Turing machine,
other than running it.
So polynomial time is good.
OK.
Let me briefly mention a
more formula-oriented game.
This is not terribly exciting.
I'll just write it down quickly.
Basically, you can convert this
problem-- team computation game
where black is forced to run
a particular machine-- you can
convert machines into formulas.
So it ends up looking
something like this.
It might be possible
to simplify.
This is one thing
that definitely works.
OK.
So again, white 1 can only
see one variable-- X1--
that is set by black.
And white 2 can only
see one variable-- X2--
that's set by black.
Black can set a bunch of
variables in one round.
And there's some condition
that it has to satisfy.
This will basically force you
to simulate the Turing machine
and not break any rules.
And if black ever
satisfies something,
which is when the Turing
machine's, hey, black wins.
Then black wins.
And then you just turn
that into a formula.
And then black sets
some other stuff.
And so this is more in the
style of the dependency QBF.
Again, you have this
kind of dependency.
But now there are
multiple rounds.
And now there's no bound to
the number of moves you make.
We can reset
variables many times.
And this is undecidable
by essentially simulating
this machine, turning that
machine into a formula.
So once we have that, we can
turn it into a constraint logic
version.
This is the team private but
not bounded constraint logic.
Pretty much the same setup.
Black has these
variables, X and X prime.
Y1 has these variables, Y1.
Y2 has these variables, Y2.
They're fed into this formula.
And there are various
things to-- that
when those conditions
that I wrote down happen,
you trigger the
appropriate target edge.
And then black wins, up there,
or white wins, down there.
So not too exciting to go
through the details of that.
But the result is team private
information constraint logic is
undecidable for three players.
And you can use a crossover.
And you can make this
planar graphs if you want.
Any more questions
about Undecidability?
AUDIENCE: Are you
ever going to give
some examples of
undecidable-- like real games?
PROFESSOR: No.
There are no known
good examples of games.
These are the games, I'm afraid.
Yeah.
Sorry.
So I would like to switch gears
and go to the extreme opposite.
Instead of Undecidability,
when there's no algorithm,
let's go back to good
old-fashioned polynomial time
algorithms.
I think you remember what P is.
But let me tell you a stronger
notion of P, which comes up
in parallel algorithms.
There are many different
models of parallel computing.
So it's a little
bit-- you know, it's
hard to write down one
good model of computation
for parallel computing.
But fortunately, if we're
proving lower bounds,
it doesn't matter whether
our model is good.
It really matters that our
model is super powerful.
If we can prove
something is impossible
in a super powerful model, that
means it's impossible in weaker
models too.
So I'm going to give you a
super powerful model called NC.
So NC is Nick's class,
named after Nick Pippinger,
who did a lot of
parallel algorithms.
And there are a few
equivalent definitions.
Let me give you two of them.
I would like my
problem to be solvable.
With P, we wanted things to
be solvable in poly time.
So a natural
improvement is that I
want to run in poly log time
for parallel algorithms,
given a huge number
of processors,
but not incredibly huge--
just polynomial number
of processors.
OK?
If I was given an exponential
number of processors,
I could solve SAT and all
sorts of crazy things.
So shouldn't go too extreme.
But let's say polynomial--
not problems but processors.
Polynomial number of
processors is reasonable, maybe
a little overkill, but OK.
With polynomial
number of processors,
I'd like to get poly log time.
That's a pretty
natural, good situation.
I let these processors
communicate however
they want, super fast.
You can think of
it as a circuit.
If you're thinking
about the p-set,
you'll be thinking about
small weft circuits.
But here, it's just good
old-fashioned depth.
We want poly log depth.
That will be the running time
if every gate of the circuit
can run in parallel.
You still have to run in
sequence, along the depth
lines.
But if there are a polynomial
number of gates-- OK,
that should be, of size.
Polynomial number of
gates and poly log depth,
then in particular, this
gives you an algorithm.
Each processor just waits
for the inputs to be ready
and then writes out the output
to the next gate that it--
or to whatever gates it has that
it's connected to by a wire.
And you get an
algorithm that runs
in poly log time, polynomial
number of processors.
So whichever you think
of is more intuitive.
OK.
So I have a small example here.
Suppose you want to sort n
numbers in the comparison
model.
You can do that.
And there are good
algorithms to do it.
I will give you a not
so great algorithm.
But at least it works in NC.
Namely, with n
squared processors,
I'm going to compare, in
parallel, all pairs of items.
I'm going to compare ai
to aj for all i and j.
Now I know which items
are less than which.
And now, for each
item i, I basically
just want to compute how many
items are smaller than it.
If there are items smaller than
it-- let's say all of the items
are distinct-- then
that item should
go to the I-th
position in the array.
So it's going to compute
this matrix, i versus j.
Each one says ai is
smaller or greater than aj.
And now, for a
given-- what do I say,
a given row-- I want to compute
how many less than signs
are in that row.
This is basically computing a
sum where I view less than as 1
and greater than as 0.
And you can compute a sum
of n items in log n time,
just by building a binary tree.
I'm going to add these
two guys in parallel
with these two guys, and so on.
And then I compute my sum.
And I can do each of
these rows in parallel.
So in log n time, I can
compute all of these sums.
Then I know where every item
needs to go and put it there.
So this is a little overkill,
that I use a ton of processors.
But still polynomial.
So in n square processors,
I can easily, in log n time,
sort n numbers.
There are more
efficient algorithms.
But the point is when
you have a par-- when
there is a parallel algorithm,
in this powerful model,
you can do it without
too much effort.
But what we're
going to show, here,
is something called
P-hardness, which,
assuming not all problems
can be solved in this--
not all polynomial time
algorithms can be solved
in this model, these
problems can't.
Just like NP hardness.
Note, in particular,
NC is contained
in P. If I had
such an algorithm,
I could simulate this algorithm.
Because I have parallelism
only polynomial,
I could simulate the whole
algorithm in polynomial time,
still.
So this is stronger
than being in P.
And P hardness means
that all problems in NC
can be reduced in the
usual Karp-style reduction,
in P reduction.
But now the reduction must
be a parallel time reduction.
So it must be an NC
algorithm to your problem.
So P-hard means you're as
hard as all problems in P.
And reductions must be
parallel algorithms.
They must in NC.
And so this implies
that you're not in NC,
assuming NC does
not equal P, which
is another standard complexity
theoretic assumption.
Makes sense-- not all problems
should be parallelizable.
So in particular,
P-hard problems
would be such problems.
And P-complete, of course,
means you're in P and P-hard.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it
be that all problems in P
can be reduced by
an NC algorithm?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Thank you.
All problems in P. Yeah.
Cool.
So all problems, presumably
including the ones
that are hard to parallelize--
not just the NC ones-- can
be reduced to your problem.
And so that means your problem
is probably in P minus NC.
Good.
So let me give you some
base P-complete problems,
starting with a very natural
one-- general machine
simulation, sequential machine.
OK?
So given a sequential algorithm,
such as a Turing machine,
run it for t steps.
Now, this is a
little bit subtle.
Let me write this down.
And then I'm going to modify it.
Does the algorithm, say,
halt within t steps?
Or does it keep running
for longer than t?
So this is a version
of the halting problem.
I mean, we-- same thing with
a nondeterministic Turing
machine.
Running for polynomial time was
our prototype for NP problems.
We've done this kind
of problem a lot.
We did a similar thing with W1.
It was a run for k steps.
And k was a parameter.
I want this problem to be in
P. But if I phrase it this way,
it would be X time complete
because t could represent
an exponentially large value.
So what I want is for
this to be encoded
in unary, which usually,
we're not supposed to do.
But here, I'm going to
explicitly say, look,
t is bounded by a polynomial
in the size of the machine--
or equivalently, it's
written in unary.
And now I can do this
in polynomial time.
Because I have t
steps to do it, I'll
just run the machine t steps.
OK?
So this is in P. And if
you believe anything is not
parallelizable, then this
shouldn't be because this
lets you simulate all things.
So pretty easy to reduce
all problems in P.
If they're in P, that means
there's an algorithm to solve
them, sequential algorithm.
So you plug it in here.
It's going to run for
only polynomial time.
So you can set t
to that polynomial.
And boom.
You know, the algorithm
halting is it's answering, yes.
Or you could change this
to returning s or whatever.
OK?
So that's actually how
you prove this problem is
P-hard, or actually P-complete.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
problem with symmetry
between yea and
no answers, here?
PROFESSOR: Here, yes
and no are the same.
Yeah.
Unlike NP.
NP had an asymmetry
between yes and no.
So I could also change
this to return no.
That would also be as hard.
Yeah.
But of course, this is
not a very useful problem.
It's just a starting point.
And it's a very natural
P-complete problem.
More useful for reductions
are these circuit
value problems, CVP.
This is going to be
like circuit set.
So with circuit set, we were
given an acyclic Boolean
circuit which had one output.
Or maybe we're given a
particular output we care
about.
And we wanted to know whether
there was some input setting
that made the output true.
Here, we are given
the input setting.
So I mean, the circuit actually
has the inputs written down,
like 0, 1, 1.
And then let's say
we take an AND,
and then we take an OR,
something like that.
And we want to know, what
is this thing at the output?
Of course, this can be
solved in polynomial time.
You compute this
AND, and you get a 0.
This was a 1.
So you compute this
OR, and you get 1.
So the answer is 1.
OK?
And you can do that
in linear time.
But to do it parallel
is really hard
because it's really
hard to predict what
these inputs are going to be.
So you can't do
anything on this gate
until the inputs are ready.
So presumably, this circuit
will not have poly log depth.
Otherwise, it isn't in NC.
But if you have a really large
debt circuit, simulating--
running it in parallel is
just as hard as this problem.
So you can reduce a
general machine simulation
to a circuit value.
And the standard way
of converting machines
into circuits, that's the
electrical engineering problem.
OK.
What was the question?
Is the output true?
OK.
Now, there are
many special cases
of this that are also hard.
For example, NAM CVP.
OK.
We know how to build
computers out of NAND.
computers out of NOR.
Cool.
So that's easy.
More interesting
is monotone CVP.
So in monotone CVP, you
just have AND and OR gates.
You don't have negation or
an AND or an OR or an XOR.
Those sorts of things.
This is also hard, essentially.
By dual-rail logic, representing
the true and the false
as separate wires and
manipulating them,
you can get this to be hard.
Also kind of similar
to constraint logic.
OK?
But I won't prove it here.
A little stronger is
alternating monotone CVP.
This alternates AND
OR down any path.
So if you take a path from
an input bit to the output,
it alternates AND
OR, AND OR, AND OR.
And furthermore, we can
assume that it starts and ends
with OR.
It's nice to nail this down.
It's not hard to prove.
But I will prove it in a
moment, once I tell you
a general enough version
that I want to analyze.
This will just let us
worry about fewer gadgets.
So up here, we had to think
about all Boolean gates.
Now we just have to
think about AND and OR.
And we can always assume
the output of an AND
is the input of an
OR, and vice versa,
and that we only need to
connect inputs to OR gates
and not like this
picture, and we only
have to get the output
from an OR gate.
So it reduces the number of
cases we need to worry about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is this
with bounded fanin?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Basically, bounded fanin
doesn't matter with this model.
So usually, when NC is defined,
it's bounded fanin and fanout.
And there's another
class, called
AC, which is when you have
unbounded fanouts and fanin,
let's say.
But that only hurts
us by a log factor.
So it matters if you're
worried about something
called AC0 and NC0, when this is
0 and you want constant height.
AUDIENCE: It matters for
alternation, as well.
PROFESSOR: Please wait, I guess.
It won't matter, is the answer.
AUDIENCE: Is this the only
setting of starting and ending
that works?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Starting and
ending with both AND
or starting with AND?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
I think you could
also make this an AND,
although I haven't checked that.
I don't think it's
critical that this is OR.
But you could probably do one
of them in OR, one of them
in AND-- all of
those combinations.
But this is the one
I've seen proved.
We'd need to check
the other cases.
But I think it's not hard.
This is called AM2CVP.
Great acronyms.
Every gate has
fanin2 and fanout2.
So in particular, bounded
but also nice and uniform.
Every single-- not less
than or equal to 2.
This is exactly 2.
OK?
We'll prove that.
And even stronger,
synchronous AM2CVP.
I prefer AVP, personally.
So this is SAM2CVP.
Synchronous means that all
of the inputs of the gate
are available at
exactly the same time.
If you imagine running all of
the gates of depth i at time i,
then you can do that.
At time i, all gates of
depth i will be ready.
They'll have all
of their inputs.
In other words, a gate of
depth i has one of its inputs
at depth i, minus 1.
But in the synchronous
circuit, both of the inputs
will have depth i, minus 1.
And so at time i, you'll
actually be ready to do it.
This is useful, in
particular, for things
like constraint logic and
other constructions, as well.
One more.
Planar CVP.
I don't know how
many of these things
you can import into
the planar case.
Probably many of them.
But just like planar circuit
set, out of NAND and NOR,
for example, you can
build crossovers.
And so planar circuits
are also hard.
But actually, not all
of them because planar
monotone CVP is in NC.
So you can't take the
monotone AND OR- ness
with planarity, which is kind
of annoying because that problem
can be done in parallel.
But planar with an AND--
then you've got negation.
And you can build a crossover.
OK.
Let me prove some
of these things.
This was to give you a
flavor for what's hard.
Still, all of these
problems up are P-complete.
And we're going to do it
in a series of reductions.
So first, let's deal with
starting and ending with OR.
So this is the
part you'd switch.
If you want to start
or end with an AND,
it should be no problem.
So this is an input bit.
Either 0 or 1, they're going
to be drawn with squares.
Oh, I should
mention, by the way,
there's a textbook
devoted to P completeness.
It's a short textbook.
But it's a nice read.
And it's online.
So I linked to it
from the website now.
So if you want to learn a little
more, check out that book.
These are figures
from that book.
So if I have some input
being sent to some gates,
I'm just going to
put an OR there.
And let's say i OR
that bit with itself.
So now everything
starts with an OR.
Done.
If I want to make
things end with an OR
and they end with an AND,
I'll just put an OR gate.
I don't know why here
we use only one input,
here we put two inputs.
But I could have just
put one input up there.
I'm allowing, for now,
one input OR gate.
So I'm going to fix that later.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Coming soon.
So this is just to
start and end with ORs.
Next thing I'd like to do
is make things alternating.
So if I have two gates--
actually, before I do this,
I need to do this later.
It's important to get
the sequence right.
First, I want to make sure
the fanout is less than
or equal to 2, in this way.
This is a standard trick.
If I have large fanout, I
just build a binary tree.
And you can put
ORs or ANDs here.
There's only one input.
So it doesn't do anything to it.
But now I have
fanout, at most, 2.
Fanin is whatever.
Did we deal with large fanin?
Not yet.
So I'm going to do that first.
This will make lots of
ORs next to each other.
But then whenever I have two ORs
or two ANDs next to each other,
I just add the opposite
gate, in between.
OK.
So now it's alternating
fanout, at most, 2.
So we've gotten this
property in a weak sense,
with less than or equal to 2.
We're going to fix the 1s later.
We haven't dealt with this yet.
I assumed-- sorry-- that
I'm starting with monotones.
So I just have ANDs and ORs.
No indication.
I'm reducing from monotone
CVP to these other problems.
I've got alternation,
starting and ending
with or and fanout, at
most, 2, at this point.
Next reduction is to
make fanin exactly 2.
So yeah.
I guess I didn't write it.
But we can use the same
trick on the other side.
If you have fanin
larger than 2, then you
can just take ANDs
and ANDs and ANDs.
So you can also get
fanin, at most, 2.
Now if I have fanin 1, which
I've used all over the place,
now I'm going to get rid of
it in two different ways.
If I have an OR gate
with one input that
happens to be an
AND or original bit,
I'll just add in
another input of 0.
That won't affect things.
And if I have an AND bit, I
would like to put a 1 here.
But I'm not allowed to feed a
number-- an input-- directly
to an AND gate because I want
to preserve the property that I
start and end with ORs.
So this is one thing
that would be--
you'd have to tweak a little
bit if you want to start and end
with ANDs.
But you can do, I
think, a similar trick.
I want to build the 1
bit using an OR gate.
So I take two one
bits, OR them together.
Now I have a 1
bit fed into here.
And then that will
just pass through.
OK?
So now I have fanin, exactly 2.
No 1s.
You can imagine this is
useful when you're actually
building gadgets
because then you don't
have to do all of the work.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I haven't
dealt with fanout 2, yet.
At this point, just fanin 2.
So variables-- some of them
still only have fanout 1.
But they will have at most, 2.
So now we're going to
do fanout, exactly 2.
So what I'm going to
do is take my circuit,
make two copies of it.
There's the primed copy
and the original copy.
OK?
So now I just need to hook
things how I want them.
The inputs, which
are not drawn here--
if I have an input out
degree 1, then I'll
merge them into one copy.
Then I'll have out degree 2.
If they already
have out degree 2,
just leave them as two copies.
OK?
So now all of the inputs have
out degree 2, or fanout 2.
If I have an AND gate
with out degree 2, again,
I don't touch it.
I'll leave them as two copies.
If I have an AND gate with
one-- a fanout of one-- then
here are the two copies of it.
I basically want to add an extra
output that gets thrown away.
So because I have
to end with an OR,
I'm going to put it OR here.
And then that's an output.
It's not the output that we're
asking the question about,
where I want to know, does
the output become true?
That's a specific output.
So for this reduction
I need to allow
there to be multiple
outputs in my circuit,
but only one of
them of interest.
OK?
And the rest is
connected as before.
So now these guys have fanout 2.
If I have an OR gate
with one output,
this is a little trickier
because I want to end with ORs,
I guess.
We're going to combine
these two bits.
And I have to alternate.
So next thing is I
have to go to an AND.
This also has to
have two outputs.
So I'm going to put one of
them here and one of them here.
These guys need two
inputs because I
don't want to [INAUDIBLE]
with the two input conditions.
So I add another bit.
It could be 0, 1.
It doesn't matter.
Feed it to both of them.
Now this has out degree 2.
These have in degree 2.
And this is an output.
So output is-- you could think
of there as being two of them.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you chain
the outputs together,
so that there's a 1 output?
PROFESSOR: Oh, combine the
different outputs together?
AUDIENCE: If you have
fanout, exactly 2,
and fanin, exactly
2, doesn't that
mean that you're preserving
the number of inputs,
So that you can't reduce
those extra outputs to 1?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Good.
So I think if we tried to
combine all of the outputs
together, we'd end up
with a similar problem.
And we'd basically have to
do this construction again,
and then produce more outputs.
Good.
Yeah.
So we violate fanin 2,
obviously, at the inputs.
But you're right.
After the input level,
the number of lines
should be preserved.
OK.
So never mind.
We do need multiple outputs.
And exactly one
of them is marked
as the one we care about,
whether an output's true.
Is that the end?
Yes.
At this point, we've proved
AM2CVP is P-complete.
OK.
So one more.
Reduction is for the
synchronous case.
This is cool.
Let me, maybe, first
say what we're doing.
So for the
synchronous reduction,
we're going to make n over 2
copies of the circuit, where
n is the number of gates.
At a high level, that's
what we're doing.
And basically,
the i-th copy will
feed into the i plus 1st copy.
Well, not quite, because we
want to alternate ANDs and ORs.
So in the i-th copy-- the
i-th copy of the circuit
will be the depth
levels 2i and 2i plus 1,
in the final circuit
that I'm producing, where
these are ANDs and inputs.
And this level is
going to be ORs.
OK?
So basically, I want to take
an AND level and an OR level
from one copy, then an
AND level and an OR level
from the next copy, and so on.
The inputs are a
little more subtle.
But in particular,
I'm at least going
to make the copies
of the inputs.
And I'm going to
change them later.
And so the outputs of
the ORs from one copy
will go to the inputs of
the ANDs in the next copy,
and vice versa.
So the outputs from the ANDs
stay within the same copy.
And then the outputs from
here go to the next copy.
Basically, this will force
synchronization, in a sense.
Now, the one tricky
part is the inputs.
I want the i-th copy to be
triggered at time 2i, exactly.
And so for that, I can't
just have the inputs.
Maybe some of the gates
in there take an input
from-- sort of straight.
I need to delay that
input from coming
and still preserve fanin and
fanout 2 and alternation.
So to do that, I'm going
to use this gadget.
So I just have the
same bit written twice.
And then I OR them
with themselves
and then AND then with
themselves and OR them.
OK?
It seems innocent enough.
That latter obviously will
not change any of the bits.
So just duplicating those
bits at every time step.
It's all about timing here.
And now here's the fun thing.
If this gate needs
this bit, obviously, I
can just take it out, here.
That will still
preserve fanout 2, here.
And if I'm taking
one bit from here,
I'm going to have to
throw away another bit.
And magically-- this is very
cool-- if I throw away a bit
here, it doesn't matter
what that bit value is.
This will still be X2.
You can think of the two cases--
either x2 is 0, in which case
this is 0, and then it doesn't
matter what this bit is.
It will output 0.
OK?
Or this bit could be a 1.
Then I go here.
And I mean, it actually doesn't
matter that it's preserved.
But it is.
I think it's kind of cool.
If this was a 1, then this will
output whatever that bit is.
But because, again,
this will be a 1
because it gets it
from here, then the OR
will turn it back into a 1.
So either way, the
bit is restored.
So you could actually
reuse this gadget
a few times if you wanted.
But we can also be lazy and just
make many copies of this gadget
because we have polynomial size.
So basically, we can get a 1
bit and also destroy an output,
basically, with
this kind of gadget,
and get the inputs to
be triggered exactly
at the right time.
So the i-th copy-- all of the
gates will trigger at time 2i.
And then all of the AND
gates will trigger at 2i.
And then all of
the OR gates will
trigger at time 2i, plus 1.
And they'll feed
into the next copy.
All of those will trigger.
And so on.
So it's a little bit redundant.
But it works.
And then the output
is going to be
the output of the last
copy, n over second copy,
I guess you'd call it.
OK.
So you can, of
course, convert this
into bounded deterministic
constraint logic, where
each edge only flips once.
Once you have the synchronous
version of CVP, it's very easy.
I didn't draw a
synchronous picture here
because it's tedious
to draw these pictures.
But if you just set these--
whichever the 1 bits are--
as your initially
active edges-- those
are the ones that just
flipped, just reversed,
then things will just
propagate and everything
will be timed exactly right,
whenever you arrive at a gate.
Both of the inputs
have just activated.
And then the output
will activate.
So just like before.
But now each edge only
has to reverse once.
And you'll get the
results at the end.
So deciding whether
the last edge flips
is the same as whether the
output was a 1 in the circuit.
Open problem, I guess, would
be to use bounded deterministic
constrain logic to
prove interesting games
P-complete or interesting
problems P-complete.
That hasn't been done.
But I have, for fun, an example
of the P completeness-- P
hardness reduction.
So suppose you want to
find an independence set.
Independence set is hard.
Suppose I want to find a
maximal independence set,
an independence set where I
can't add anymore vertices.
So here's a way to do that.
I start with nothing.
I do a for loop.
Let's say the
vertices are numbered.
It's going to be important.
And if I can add
that vertex, add it.
If V is not adjacent
to S, add it.
OK.
I mean, this whole
world is weird
because it's all about
polynomial time problems.
Here's a polynomial
time algorithm.
It produces what I would call
the lexically first maximal
independence set because
it adds 1, if it can.
And then, subject to that, it
adds 2 if it can, and so on.
I will always add one, I guess.
So with this
labeling of vertices,
it finds the lexically
smallest one.
Suppose you want to find
the lexically smallest
maximal independence set.
finding a maximal independence
set can be done in parallel.
But finding the lexically
smallest one cannot.
This is P-complete.
And the reduction is super cute.
Reduction from NOR CVP.
Suppose I give
you a NOR circuit,
and I want to know whether
the output becomes true.
What I'm going to do is
build a special vertex,
called 0, which is connected
to all of the 0 inputs.
So the circuit has 0
inputs and 1 inputs.
I'm going to make the
inputs into nodes.
OK?
And so there are some 1 nodes.
Those are just
going to be nodes.
They connect to
whatever the gates are.
Then these things are combined
with various gates, and so on.
I'm just going to replace
a gate with a node.
I'm going to replace
an input with a node.
And I'm going to add
a special node, 0,
which is numbered
first, that connects
to all of the 0 inputs.
And then I'm also going
to order the vertices
in a topological sort.
So this will have
the earliest number.
Then these guys.
And so on.
So any topological sort.
Lemma topological sorting
can be done in parallel.
There's an NC algorithm
for topological sorting.
We need that here because this
reduction has to be in NC.
But once you do
that, I claim that V
will be in S if, and only
if, that gate outputs a 1.
Proof by induction.
So initially, this
is going to be
put in the independent set,
which means these guys won't,
but these guys will because
they're lexically first--
or they're first in
the topological order--
and then induction.
There's only one
type of gate here.
It's a NOR.
So basically, this
guy will be circled
if, and only if, neither
of the inputs are circles.
So that's a NOR.
And so then the
decision question
is there's some last thing
corresponding to the output.
It's going to be circled if, and
only if, the circuit outputs 1.
And that's it.
It's kind of a
beautiful reduction.
And I just, for fun, I have a
list of some more P-complete
problems without proofs.
Game of Life, obviously.
When you're given a time bound
that is written in unary,
and I want to know, is this
cell alive at time t, where
t is written in unary, by
the proof we did already,
that's P-complete.
And just, it's with
the unary version.
Also, one-dimensional
cellular automata.
Same kind of thing.
Generalize geography.
Remember that PSPACE
complete problem.
But if you have an
acyclic directed graph,
and you want to solve
geography on an acyclic
directed graph-- so it's
a two player game-- that
can be done in polynomial time.
But it's P-complete.
If I have a point
set in the plane,
and I compute the convex
hull, remove those points,
compute the convex hull,
remove those points,
it's called an onion peeling.
And given a point, I want to
know, is it on the k-th layer
for some value k,
that's P-complete.
Basically, you have to
sequentially compute
the convex hulls.
Another good canonical
one is multilist ranking.
Suppose I give you k, say,
sorted lists of numbers,
and I want to know,
given an item,
what is its rank in
the union of the lists?
So items can appear
in multiple lists.
And I want to know, is it the
kth item, in sorted order,
in the union?
So basically, I want
to sort the union.
That's P-complete.
If I want to compute A mod
B1, mod B2, mod B3, mod B4,
n times-- so the
repeated mod-- I
want to know whether that
equals 0, that's P-complete.
If I wanted to--
linear programming,
that's polynomial time.
This is P-complete, even when
the coefficients are 0 and 1.
So this is called
strongly P-complete.
You don't need large numbers,
whereas something like max flow
is weakly P-complete and can be,
in the analogy to full P test--
fully polynomial time
approximation scheme-- there
is a fully RNC
approximation scheme.
R means there's randomization.
I think it's open, whether
you can get rid of that.
There's some fun open problems,
like deciding whether two
numbers are relatively prime.
It's conjectured
to be P-complete.
But we don't know.
Computing A or the B mod C is
conjectured to be P-complete.
Maximum matching is conjectured
to be-- with large edge
weights, it's conjectured
to be P-complete.
But there is a
pseudo RNC algorithm.
So if the weights are small,
and you allow randomization,
then it's parallelizable.
Another open problem
is graph isomorphism
with bounded degree,
which is polynomial time.
I didn't know that.
But bounded degree
graph isomorphism
is easy in a serial setting.
But a conjecture is it's
hard in a parallel setting.
So lots of things out there.
I don't see too many
papers about P completeness
these days.
But it's a fun thing.
Once you decide your problem is
in P, next thing, next level,
you can find hardness
anywhere, it turns out.
Next thing is to prove P
completeness for your problem,
make sure there's no
parallel algorithm,
or find an NC algorithm.
If you do the upper bound
side, once you have NC,
you want to get the
smallest depth possible.
That's another story.
Cool.
That's it for today.